world war two was fought by every major
middle power in the world and very few
parts of it were left unscarred there is
one notable exception to this the
Republic of Turkey now whilst they did
nominally declare war in 1945 just as
Germany was about to fall its soldiers
never saw combat and to pretty frankly
turkey still wasn't too keen on joining
the war so how did turkey managed to
stay out of the war for so long and even
when it did join it only did so under
direct pressure and because without
doing so it would be sidelined in the
post-war world it's crucial to remember
that in the years leading up to World
War two Turkey was still recovering from
its war of independence which did
tremendous damage to the country this
was followed by major reforms in a
period of the country's first president
Mustafa Kemal atatürk attempting to
strengthen turkeys global position
Turkey's position was a strange one
since in 1939 you were often either a
great power or a colony and Turkey was
neither as such it was able to forge its
own course and was capable of resisting
its larger neighbors in a way that many
European nations couldn't in October of
1939 shortly after the outbreak of the
war Turkey signed a mutual assistance
pact with Britain and France which made
it pretty clear that Turkey lent towards
the Allied camp the reason why turkey
was less friendly towards the axis
wasn't because of some dislike for
Germany since the two nations actually
had good relations it was in fact down
to turkish italian tensions due to
mussolini wanting to dominate the
Mediterranean so the mutual assistance
pact wasn't the same as joining the
Allies it saw Britain give turkey a lot
of money to modernize and increase the
size of its army turkey was still
determined to stay out of the war though
as demonstrated by President T nany when
he stated that for us war is out of the
question unless we are left absolutely
no choice this is why despite Britain
and France being at war with Germany
Turkey still continued to trade with
both sides still with the Turkish
weren't interested in fighting a war in
which there was little benefit for
themselves make no mistake though if
turkey had to choose it would pick
Britain and a staunch ally France who
had just capitulated and also Italy had
joined the war oops
whilst we all know how the war ended it
wasn't so clear at the time and for
Turkey it now faced greater pressure
from both sides to pick one and since
Germany in Italy we're doing very well
against the Allies turkey needed to make
sure they stayed on good terms with them
in June of 1941 turkey in Germany signed
a treaty of friendship because he nan
who had concerns that Stalin was going
to act on his territorial ambitions for
Hitler this also kept Turkey out of the
war which allowed him to turn his
attention to the USSR which he invaded
only three
days after the friendship treaty was
signed as she'll probably know the
invasion went really well then less well
then pretty badly it was at this point
that allied pressure on Turkey was at
its highest the American President
Franklin D Roosevelt was content with
turkey staying out of the war but
Winston Churchill the British prime
minister had up the plans
Churchill was convinced that the secret
to success was attacking Germany soft
underbelly ie the Balkans which he would
need Turkish assistance in fighting it
wasn't until the outcome of the war was
clear that Turkey opted to cease trading
with Germany and in February of 1945
Turkey declared war this came after
obtaining a guarantee that the US and UK
would help Turkey in the event of a
Soviet invasion after the war thus we
concede that the reason turkey stayed
out of the war for as long as possible
are pretty simple its leaders wish to
spare the country the horrors of war
which I had known all too well over the
previous decades there was frankly
little to be gained for turkey and
joining either the axis or the Allies
barring some future guarantees turkeys
joining of the war stem not from wanting
to get involved but from fear of being
sidelined by the international community
after the war had ended I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with extra thanks to my patrons
that you see on screen now and a special
thanks to James Bissonnette party-boy co
Zarqa flash chris wicker Rob Waterhouse
Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan
Maggie packs Kowski Winston k-word
rafail Adam Harvey Anthony Beckett Skye
Chappell and the amusement park Ives
you